Dixie Chicks if I have the story right
was not a name you came up with it was
your two partners and you joined the
Dixie Chicks yeah you never were
involved in the naming of the band when
I joined the band they did say you know
should we change our name like they just
hated their name it was a last-minute
decision on their way to the street
corner to play for tips and they needed
a name because people kept asking them
what are you called
and so they heard the Little Feat song
if you'll be my Dixie chicken I'll be
your Tennessee lamb and we're like Oh
we'll be the Dixie chickens and they
were that for a couple of weeks and then
they sure Marty didn't want to be a
chicken
so they shortened it to chicks and then
when I joined the band they were like
you know we're getting a new lead singer
so this could be a good time to change
the name we've always hated my our name
and I was like no no your name is the
one good thing about you did you think
their band was bad actually when you
joined it did you feel like you needed
to elevate them it wasn't my kind of
music I didn't listen to country music
but they were even beyond country music
they were Western Swing
but I loved Marty Emily's ability and
thought that that was really special how
awesome they are at their instruments
and so yeah I thought we could do
something cool you think fans should
destroy their t-shirts and memorabilia
that say Dixie Chicks should they have
totally embraced the new name and get
rid of all that stuff you know when we
actually changed our name and when we
made the March March video we consulted
with movement leaders from all the
different movements and black lives
matter like any time we have to do a new
pressing of an old album does it now say
the chicks and they say no like you have
your Creator I don't know what you call
it suppose in the pre and that people
know who we are and what's in our hearts
I mean we didn't have any Dixie Chicks
because we're racists we and the track
we always got for our name was four
chicks
it really wasn't ever for Dixie Dixie
made us uncomfortable at a certain point
but we also didn't feel like it was
representative of us we're not from
Dixie the area that was called Dixie but
so so I you know it was just sort of a
word I didn't think a
all the history behind it or how the
word came to be or how it might make
black people feel write our name wasn't
any sort of statement but changing it
was a statement and we didn't want to
make a big deal about it we didn't
really press release we just changed all
the social medias we just did it because
this moment isn't about us this moment
is about something so much bigger and
we're just trying to live up to that and
and also the chicks is such a cooler
name why didn't we think of it before